foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
the desperate mission to rescue the
trout after three trains Collide in
eastern India killing at least 80 people
my career is over Phillip Schofield
denies an abuse of power but insists ITV
bosses could have done more to
investigate his affair
that was
a very very grave error now it was
consensual
but it was my fault
he froze to death in his brother's arms
the five-hour delay to rescue migrants
in the Mediterranean which left 94 dead
[Music]
[Applause]
unjustified and abhorrent condemnation
after Roma fans Harris referee Anthony
Taylor after the Europa League final
foreign
convert radicalized during lockdown
today jailed for plotting to murder a
police officer or Soldier
[Music]
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening we begin tonight in eastern
India where a desperate rescue mission
is underway after three trains collided
at least 80 passengers have been killed
though the number of confirmed dead is
expected to rise and hundreds more are
injured the country's prime minister
Narendra Modi says he's distressed by
the disaster which happened near the
city of balasore as Skies Neville
Lazarus reports
they are cutting open the mangled
remains of a passenger train to rescue
those who are trapped after yet another
Collision on India's underfunded rail
network
this Express train was carrying hundreds
of passengers from Kolkata to Chennai
when it derailed and a dozen of its
coaches overturned
as I stepped out of the Train's bathroom
suddenly it tilted I lost my balance I
held on to something I almost fell my
body tilted my slippers my bag
everything went topsy-turvy and people
started falling all over each other
as it lay on its side and those inside
tried to escape another collision and
then another this time an incoming
freight train crashing into the wreckage
there are many who have died and so many
injured hella saved us today
hello
hundreds of workers from the security
forces the national disaster rescue
force and fire services are involved in
search and rescue Nightfall has added to
the challenge the Prime Minister tweeted
distressed by the train accident in
odisha in this hour of grief my thoughts
are with the berry families neither
injured recovered soon
hospitals and districts have been put on
high alert rescue workers are racing
Against Time
and with each minute the chance of
finding someone alive is fading never
Lazarus Sky News Delhi
former this morning presenter Phillip
Schofield returned to the screens today
and admitted his career was over after
Revelations he lied about his affair
with a young male ITV employee but ahead
of a key Hearing in Westminster next
week he insisted bosses at the channel
could have done more to investigate the
relationship either Bennett reports he's
used to asking the questions but now
Philip schofield's having to answer them
the former ITV presenter going back in
front of the camera and denying his
affair with a younger male colleague who
was 15 when they met amounted to
grooming what was unwise was the fact
that
it happened
and that was a very very grave error now
it was consensual
but it was my fault good morning pack
show for you today the 61 year old
resigned from the ITV show this morning
after admitting to the relationship last
week now explaining it became sexual
when the colleague was 20.
a fixture of our screens for so long he
now believes his career is over and says
he's been having suicidal thoughts
likening his current situation to that
faced by another former ITV presenter
Caroline Flack before she took her own
life in 2020. I don't see a future
and so how much
do you want a man to take and are you
truly only happy
when he's dead and this is how Caroline
Flack felt for his former this morning
co-stars the interview was hard to watch
you know I loved Phillip Schofield and
it's weird because I still love Phillip
Schofield however what he's done is
wrong he's admitted he said sorry but
I'm really I mean as a family we're all
really um struggling to process
everything a way back with them may not
be possible but some believe schofield's
career isn't done yet for sure it seems
impossible that he could come back from
this but having been around for a very
long time it's amazing how over time
these things can be rehabilitated
careers like his even after a terrible
terrible crisis for ITV though questions
remain about why their investigation
didn't get to the truth Schofield agreed
it could have been more thorough ITV has
now announced an external review led by
a barrister into who knew what and when
here but we still don't know the terms
of that review nor its time frame and
MPS will be demanding answers as soon as
next week that's when ITV chief
executive Dame Carolyn McCaw will be
grilled by politicians for them this is
much bigger than just Scofield and this
morning it's about safeguarding
whistleblowing and the Integrity of
Public Service broadcasting either
Bennett Sky News
and if you or anyone you know has been
affected by the content of that story
please remember you can call the
Samaritans on 116123 or email Joe at
samaritans.org
it's one of the deadliest Journeys for
migrants attempting to reach Europe more
than a thousand people have already died
this year attempting to cross the
Mediterranean one of them six-year-old
Sultan froze to death in his brother's
arms after his boat broke apart in
stormy seas
Sky News has been investigating whether
he could have been saved if Italian
authorities had acted earlier to launch
a rescue mission passengers set off from
says may on the Turkish Coast at 3am on
February the 22nd
they were spotted three days later by a
border patrol plane which alerted the
authorities but did not class the boat
as in distress
less than an hour later with weather
conditions worsening two vessels were
sent to help but both turned back
the first distress call was received at
4am when the summer love was already
sinking 94 people drowned that morning
three officers from the Italian Italian
military police are now being
investigated for failing to act our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
reports
on the 26th of February Italy witnessed
one of the worst migrant boat crashes in
decades
what is my
um
at least 94 people died
around 35 are believed to be children
but could more have been done to save
them
Sky News working with Media Partners
across Europe and Lighthouse reports has
spent more than two months investigating
the journey started in Chesney and
turkey on the 22nd of February when
around 180 people boarded The Smuggler's
boat heading to Calabria in Italy hours
into the trip they broke down and
transferred onto the summer love vessel
Mediterranean is one of the most
dangerous migrant routes in the world
more than a thousand people have already
died this year attempting to get to
Europe
32 year old Zarin paid 8 000 Euros to
cross after fleeing violence in
Afghanistan he was hoping for a new life
this 3D reconstruction shows you how
overcrowded the boat was almost 200
people packed inside
while the Smugglers stayed up top
the families were crammed Below in
little rooms for most of the journey
they say there were no life jackets much
of the time they were locked in to avoid
detection
initially the weather was good here as
small group celebrates believing they've
reached Italian Waters
[Music]
they have no idea they're heading
towards a storm a storm and a fatal
crash
more than five hours before the crash
some alive is spotted by a frontex
border patrol plane Eagle One
at 10 26 Italian time the heat-seeking
cameras show one person on Deck but pick
up a significant thermal response noting
more people could be below they alert
the Italian authorities to the ship as a
suspected migrant vessel and note no
life jackets are visible
strong winds have already disrupted
their flight but despite this they do
not class the boat as in distress
yeah
in the hours that follow the weather
worsens Italian authorities send out two
boats to intercept the summer love but
both turn around due to the storm
no rescue operation is launched
this doesn't happen until the first
distress call is received at around 4am
by which time the summer love is sinking
and dozens of people are drowning
foreign
Assad was on board with his uncle and
six-year-old brother Sultan they'd fled
Syria hoping to meet family in Germany a
new life Sultan would never live to see
foreign
to death in his brother's arms his uncle
shows us his little grave
after the boat sank Rescuers scoured the
sand for survivors
the desperate
who'd managed to make it to shore
but the body bags kept on lining up
an eight-month-old baby and 70 year old
pensioner believed to be among the Dead
who do you blame for what happened that
night
um
we contacted the Italian Coast Guard and
Guardia de finanza to ask why a rescue
wasn't launched sooner they said they
couldn't comment due to an ongoing
investigation into the crash
frontex denied any wrongdoing saying
when they filmed the boat it wasn't in
distress
and that all of their findings went to
the Italian authorities who have the
power to launch a search and rescue
but many who made this Crossing hoping
for new lives believe they were
forgotten
Siobhan Robbins Sky News
Europe's football governing body today
condemned violent behavior and promised
to review its security protocol after a
British referee was abused by fans after
the Europa League final the acrimony
began on the pitch and continued into
the car park when Jose Mourinho
confronted Anthony Taylor the Roma coach
has now been given a two-match ban as
our Europe correspondent Adam Parsons
reports foreign
s at Budapest Airport angry their team
lost the Europa League final and now
convinced they had found the person to
blame
Anthony Taylor the English referee
traveling home with his family the focus
of all this abuse the group just about
safely ushered into a side room at the
airport moments later a chair is hurled
in their Direction
he's got his wife out there to witness
one of the greatest days of his life
he's done the game had a real real tough
match he's at the airport coming back
and that's not the memories you want but
was this man the Catalyst Jose Mourinho
the Roma manager was one of 14 people
booked during an ill-tempered match
he then waited in the car park to
confront the referee
congratulations
swearing at him in multiple languages
and calling Taylor a disgrace
Mourinho like both the clubs involved in
this game has now been charged by UEFA
with breaking rules but it was at the
airport where anger turned into violence
I think there is an absolute link
between the culture of the football team
the players that are playing
at the manager and therefore it
resonates to supporters absolutely it's
absolutely distinct sympathy to from
other football managers I'm so sorry for
for the images I saw for Anthony Taylor
I'm so sorry
so hopefully not don't happen again so
there's only I can say all referees have
a really difficult job and you know
shouldn't be put through any situations
which I heard this morning and uh you
know that's not correct
Anthony Talley used to be a prison
officer he's a robust character but he
didn't expect or deserve this nor did
the family who had to cow with him on an
ugly day for football Adam Parsons Sky
News
Sky News understands a sitting labor MP
has filed a complaint against Garrett
Davies after he was suspended over
allegations of inappropriate behavior it
comes after another labor MP Charlotte
Nichols claimed a colleague who was
reported to the police for alleged
sexual assault is still on the
opposition front bench because the party
has in her words chosen not to act
let's go straight to Westminster now and
our chief political correspondent and
John pressure on labor tonight over
their handling of the allegations it
seems
well Charlotte Nichols has certainly uh
stirred up her controversy claiming that
someone who has had complaints against
them is still on the front bench not the
back benches uh because as you say the
party chose not to act she didn't name
the MP but she said she uh challenged
labor officials their response has been
utterly inadequate now as for garine
Davis the labor MP for Swansea West uh
Sky News understands there is now a
second complaint about his behavior this
one from a labor MP the first one are
probably not a labor MP now in regards
to the initial allegations Mr Davis told
the Politico website he didn't recognize
the allegations he didn't know who
they'd come from and he said if I've
inadvertently caused offense to anyone
then I'm naturally sorry now an another
development concerning Mr Davis tonight
night regarding the allegation that he
took sex workers into Parliament and
boasted about it to colleagues well Mr
Davis is tonight denying that allegation
eseed says he denies the claims he says
they're false and that he has instructed
his lawyers to uh to in relation to them
so after all those years it seems
pessminster is back and it's at the
moment it seems to be the labor party
that's facing questions as to how it's
handling it
John thank you very much
I just want to bring you some updated
news now out of Eastern India we've um
got further details and sadly the the
number of people that have died
following that rail crash has now been
revised up to 120 that is the latest
figure with the Proviso from Indian
officials that that number May well
continue to rise we know that three
trains collided in uh India's eastern
odisha state
initially more than 50 ambulances were
sent to the scene that's near the city
of a balasore and one of the trains
involved in the Collision was the
coromandel express
so that figure sadly has risen this
evening to 120 people who have lost
their lives in that train crash in
eastern India
a teenage Muslim convert who became
radicalized during lockdown was just 24
hours away from carrying out a terrorist
attack when he was arrested that's
according to police a court heard
Matthew King wanted to torture and kill
an American all-british Soldier and had
previously spoken about planning a mass
casualty event today he was sentenced to
a minimum of six years behind bars Becky
Cottrell reports
what you're watching is the initial
planning of a terror attack
eighteen-year-old Matthew King walks
past police officers before taking a
photo of them and posting it on social
media with the caption Target acquired
here he is checking out an army barracks
prosecutors said he wanted to kill on
duty police or military personnel he
also looked into traveling to Syria to
join Isis Matthew King had converted to
Islam he'd been in trouble at school and
had been expelled initially his behavior
seemed to improve with his new focus on
religion but everything changed when
covid hit and there were National
lockdowns
it was during this time when he was
isolated that he became radicalized
online it is clear that you are someone
who
'd entrenched
the Western views and that you intended
to commit terrorist acts both in UK and
overseas
these are some of items King purchased
he also tried to set up an account
needed to buy a knife online it's
tempting to think he didn't pose a lot
of danger given that this was a probably
a low sophistication terrorist attack
using bladed instruments however this
was a really serious threat to the
public and to colleagues and to the Army
and really for me this was an imminent
terrorist attack and we needed to
disrupt it
received concern calls about King's
Behavior Inc including from his own
mother who was so worried she reported
him to the counter-terrorism program
prevent and after one of his Sinister
reconnaissance missions he was arrested
although it was King's family who put
him on the police's radar in a letter to
the judge they said they'll always
support him it is thanks to them that
his desire to kill never became a
reality Becky Cottrell Sky News at the
Old Bailey
an neonatal nurse who's on trial for
killing seven babies and attempting to
kill 10 others has denied getting a
thrill from the grief and despair of the
parents whose children she allegedly
murdered today in her tenth day of
evidence Lucy letby was accused of
falsifying medical charts to cover up
her actions as Katarina vertotsi reports
the cross-examination of Lucy letby
continued today focusing on a baby girl
She's accused of trying to murder four
times before she eventually died
the prosecution allege that letby
fatally injected the baby with air at
the counters of Chester Hospital in
October 2015 claims the nurse vigorously
denies
today here at Manchester Crown Court the
prosecution claimed that Lucy let the
falsified timings on care notes in order
to as they put it cover her tracks the
court heard that on the night that baby
I died Lucy letby wasn't the child's
designated nurse and had instead been
assigned to look after other babies in
different rooms on the neonatal Ward
but the prosecution says despite that
medical notes show that it was Lucy
letby that was by the child cot side
alone when she suddenly deteriorated
that's the truth isn't it that you were
in there when child eye was crying
relentlessly and no one else was there
the prosecution said potentially yes
letby replied
the former nurse was also questioned
about her behavior after the child had
died the court had a statement from the
baby's mother who was bathing her dead
child on the ward and said
Lucy came back in she was smiling she
kept going on about how she was present
at child eye's first bath and how much
she loved it
it wasn't meant with any malice Lucy
letby said we still talk to babies we
still treat them like they are alive I
was just trying to reflect on a happier
memory but the prosecution said you were
getting a thrill watching that the grief
the despair you were watching in that
room weren't you absolutely not the
former nurse replied
prosecution questioning of Lucy letby
will continue next week over what
happened between June 2015 and 2016 she
denies the murder of seven babies and
the attempted murder of ten others
Catherine of utotsi Sky News in
Manchester
now to a trend said to be fast becoming
the crime of choice violent watch
robberies have nearly doubled since 2015
and luxury timepieces have rocketed in
value after the pandemic thieves now
track their targets using social media
forcing some sellers to offer
chauffeur-driven cars to customers who
make expensive purchases Rachel
Venable's reports contains violent
scenes from the start
followed threatened and beaten for their
watches
[Music]
on the streets of Britain watch thefts
are on the rise
there's the break there break there and
a break there Nick Triggs and his wife
were attacked at random and robbed in
West London last January a black BMW X5
screeches to a hawk beside me
the door opens
a guy gets out and smashes me on the
left cheekbone there's a another person
showing me a 15-inch machete I think is
he going to kill me
after a police helicopter chase through
Central London six men were eventually
caught and convicted these are the sorts
of areas The Gangs operate in they'll
wait outside high-end restaurants or
bars even watch shops and they also use
social media to find their victims if
you post a picture of your expensive
watch say with your live location or
they know where to find you
in many areas it's actually over taken
drugs as the crime of choice for some
criminal gangs drugs are obviously very
dangerous to carry to hold to transport
whereas what is are very simple I'm very
rarely questioned as an example you
can't get on a plane with a kilo of
cocaine but you can get on a plane with
a million pounds for stolen watches and
I very much doubt that anyone will even
bat an eyelid since 2015 the number of
watches stolen in England and Wales has
nearly doubled more than 11
000 were stolen last year over half here
in London so here we have a Rolex
Daytona with a mother of pearl dial with
diamond indexes since the pandemic
there's been a boom in the value of
second-hand watches that's what's
driving the criminals not a lot of
watches were produced so
um the value increased massively this
would have been around a hundred
thousand pounds just before lockdown
today it's around 185 000. Danny's
become so worried he's now offering a
free chauffeur service to get customers
home safely these gangs have clearly
found an easy way to make a lot of money
with little care of how their violence
scars their victims Rachel Venable's Sky
News